this is what they're calling the don't  say gay build  [Music]  although the word gay is not even in the  bill  not that there's anything wrong with  that they don't want sexual orientation  or any discussion of sex or gender  identity  mentioned to children in public school  from kindergarten to third grade he's  just a kid and if you really want to see  what's wrong with them here's some other  florida state senators talking about  this scary bill do we really think that  teachers are engineering students to  become gay because we oppose the bill  we're pedophiles more or less yes free  state of florida  not if you're gay slam poetry imagine  saying to a first grader uh talk to me  about your feelings about sexual  identity or your gender it's absolutely  psychotic we all know it is